one of the things that we found really
interesting just the difference between
the scan and the actual print from the
scan for something is technically
sophisticated as the engine they don't
match up and we expected that people who
wanted to look at the air engine would
get really upset because you know the
valves were a little bit out of place or
this pipe or that pipe actually wasn't
complete but we found that the scan
itself was such high fidelity that when
you put it over even a not quite
accurate or quite inaccurate model
people were completely fooled they
believe their eyes over their fingers
their eyes trick them into thinking that
this was really accurate and they were
just blown away completely blown away
so it's mounted on something that
actually looks like it makes sense in a
museum context it's one of these little
you know acrylic boxes that you would
hold something precious in that's
actually holding the tracker so that the
line of sight isn't occluded so that it
can track properly and then mount it on
top of that nice and firmly is the
actual object and because the objects is
fully available to your hands from any
angle you could pick it up turn it
upside down look at it however you like
the pilot project was done in
collaboration with Darby Museum and it
was hosted at the Derby Museum and Art
Gallery which is in the center of Darby
Darby has this incredible history of
manufacturing so for example Rolls Royce
is quite nearby and this in particular
is a scan that they made of their aero
engine which we then used in the VR
experience and the aero engine was
basically one of the two engines that
powered the first transatlantic flight
we also chose some other objects again
with the guiding principle of size and
fragility so we have a painted object
that if too many people touched it the
paint would come off so nobody can ever
touch it we had something made of glass
and one thing that we were really
excited about is we had something that
looks not terribly exciting
but it was a mystery object because they
found it in their stores and they
guessed that it had something to do with
the region's long tradition of making
silk and lace and fabrics but they
weren't quite sure what it was and out
of our first pilot with just two dozen
people one of the people recognized it
I think her grandmother had worked in
the factory or something she said oh I
know what that is I've seen one of those
when I was a little girl and she was
actually able to tell the museum what
their object was and one of the elements
that we were very interested in as well
is looking at storytelling if you sit
down at the pub with a friend and have a
chat
that's conversational storytelling
you're telling stories back and forth to
each other and then you can imagine
someone who gets paid fast amounts of
money to go to a big hall and tell a
proper story you've paid lots of money
to go and see that storytelling and so
what are the various factors that nudge
you towards one or the other and so what
we wanted to do here is to make people
feel comfortable enough that they would
open up in front of a camera in a public
place in front of people they don't know
but also get them to feel a little bit
under pressure so that they didn't lapse
into just chatting so that they thought
about something that might be worthwhile
for other people to listen to so we
built a VR environment so that people
could engage with the museum objects and
engage with them using passive haptics
so that they could reach out and touch
them and get really engaged within that
way or at least we hoped they would get
engaged that way and it turns out that
they did it reminds me a lot of
childhood messing around with model kits
and having those as sort of something I
used to spend a lot of time doing and
then because they were so engaged with
this and they were able to experience it
in their own way in their own time and
we carefully nudged them and asked them
Oh does this make you think of anything
there's a remind you of anything
what about it excites you then they were
prepared to tell our story and we wanted
to make sure that they felt comfortable
enough that they could think of
something to say and
at stage fright but we wanted them to
say a complete thing that could be sort
of a unit a story of video that people
would watch and that the museum's could
use and show to other people and put on
their social media anything that they
wanted to use it for which of course the
people would give access to the museum's
for that museums didn't just take it
this is all very explicit in the VR
environment to help with that we set up
a set of lights and a camera and when
they were ready the flood lights came on
and the camera came on so they really
knew like this is the moment I'm telling
a story and I need to make sense while
these lights are on and then they were
done and the can't the lights and the
camera shut off and nothing had actually
happened because this is all in VR we
would come in later and cut the story
where it needed to be cut but to them it
felt like they were in this museum space
full of museum objects and someone with
a camera and lights was capturing their
story and so they felt like they had
really invested something of themselves
and built more of a relationship with
the museum and and given something to
the museum of their own personal
connection to the objects so this now
verbally can be brought into VR you can
use a newer optical tracking
technologies but to the output that you
would want for the word dog so it's
gonna have to put those two words close
together if it wants to do well at this
task